Cool! You sure don't seem too freaked out about all
this kid what you doing out there all by yourself
anyway exploring the world sounds fun but why
stop at one world when we can show you all of them
I am the watcher
I am your guide through these vast new realities
follow me and dare to face the unknown
and ponder the question what if
give me the tour
Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel what
if trailer video we also have some more details
about what they're doing with the series in
this new version of the multiverse avengers
that it seems like the watcher is assembling
from across all kinds of different realities
so we'll break it all down there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs pretty safe bet that it's going to
wind up being the craziest series coming during
marvel phase 4. i will be doing all the episode
videos for this this summer when it drops after
the loki's series this is coming right after loki
there'll be 10 episodes of this so it'll be one
of the longer marvel series and it's going to
get multiple seasons for obvious reasons when
you're talking about theoretical situations
what if zombie captain america what if a version
of ultron assembled all the infinity stones and
became a living infinity gauntlet that is actually
one of the episodes that they're doing you can do
hundreds of episodes of this series before you
burn through all the really good ideas so we'll
talk about the new previews and the new footage
that we got then i'll talk about the multiverse
avengers that they're putting together they're
calling the team the guardians of the multiverse
so you may have seen promos or teasers of this
floating around the internet it's basically where
they're taking the what if series they're taking
it way beyond the concept of the original comic
book the original what if series was mostly just
a bunch of one-off stories like what if wolverine
had fought thanos during avengers end game what
would that have looked like but then typically
in the comic book they wouldn't continue that
storyline it would just be one issue of that
comic book and then in the next issue it would be
a completely different character in a completely
different reality a different scenario so just
based on the idea that they're putting together
this multiverse team of alternate versions of all
these characters it sounds like there's gonna be
a serialized narrative and probably by season two
they'll change the paradigm of the show and it'll
be more about the team going around to different
realities but the brand new stuff that we just
got a little while ago were new looks at this
version of iron man is not clear which reality
he's from the footage of iron man in the trailer
is from the events of iron man 2 inside the giant
donut which is an actual place in los angeles that
i've been to you can actually go buy donuts there
there's not a ton of footage of him there and
obviously he doesn't speak during the trailer
so we don't know who's going to be voicing the
character i'm assuming that robert downey jr would
come back to do his character but i think when
they were working on this series working on the
actual episodes they were still trying to figure
out a new deal with him to come back and do that
we got new looks at this version of iron man
with a brand new iron man armor suit that's
way more cosmic way more hardcore we just saw
a version of gamora in full thanos armor from
avengers end game wielding thanos double bladed
sword from avengers end game so it seems like
they're implying that this version of gamora
either becomes thanos or replaces thanos after
probably killing him that was part of the pitch
of the character at the beginning of the first
guardians of the galaxy movie like she was the
model daughter that thanos favored over a nebula
because she was so hardcore with a character
like that you can go either one of two ways
obviously the way we saw her go was she rebelled
against thanos joins the guardians of the galaxy
and became a fundamentally good character but the
other path you would take that story would be her
becoming even more hardcore in judging thanos
eventually killing him and taking his throne
there's a slightly different version of the
collector he actually shows up in the trailer
too so it's the same version of the collector i'm
assuming this is also during the guardians of the
galaxy footage because there is a lot of guardians
of the galaxy in black panther crossover footage
there's another picture of this new version of
loki who seems like he was more successful in
taking over earth just because he's wearing that
same armor from the first avengers movie is it
seems like he's marching in with them to address
the united nations then like i mentioned earlier
there's this new version of ultron which seems
like all six infinity stones embedded in his armor
the most powerful form ultron has ever taken like
he becomes a living infinity gauntlet because he's
been able to integrate all the infinity stones
into his programming in his body and obviously
this looks like a much further upgraded version of
his body from what we saw during avengers age of
ultron the whole idea is that he was going to put
himself in vision's body so he would have looked
like vision he would have just sounded like ultron
i also love that he's got this pole arm weapon
that looks really cool and the cape as if he would
need an actual weapon even without the infinity
stones he's a living weapon he can make any weapon
that he would need he doesn't need to carry one
around and because he has the infinity stones in
whatever's happening during this ultron episode
he's basically the most powerful living weapon
in the universe so it's a little funny to see him
walking around with a weapon it'd be like seeing
galactus wield a giant sword like you don't need
a sword you wield the power cosmic then you've
probably seen this promo art of the multiverse
avengers team the guardians of the multiverses
they're calling them you'd also make a reference
to the guardians of the galaxy like guardians
of the galaxy but make it from the multiverse
based on the way they're presenting this just in
frame it seems like uwatu helps bring the team
together and guides them it seems like they're
implying peggy carter captain britain leads this
version of this team the same way that captain
america steve rogers leads the regular avengers
then you have black panther star-lord who just
seems like a way more chill version of the mcu
version of black panther a version of black widow
not really clear what's different about her during
the what if series we haven't seen any trailer
footage of her yet it just seems like she's an
alternate version of natasha black widow i think
maybe this is the idea that she didn't die during
the events of avengers end game because whichever
reality she comes from probably just didn't
experience the events of avengers infinity war in
avengers end game there's a version of killmonger
he's wearing his same armor from the black panther
movie it's not clear what else is different about
him i mean he has this really hardcore look on
his face and it's not clear if he also comes from
that same black panther guardians of the galaxy
episode where a young version of t'challa winds up
going with the ravagers he could come from another
episode i'm just assuming for now he's associated
with the black panther episode there's that
version of gamora it's probably the same version
of gamora that became thanos or replaced thanos
there's this new version of thor that some other
promo art was calling the party version of thor
so i don't know if they're just calling him party
thor or what else is different about him but it
seems like this version of thor is from the events
of the first avengers movie because he's got that
same armor he's still got mjolnir so wherever he's
coming from he hasn't experienced the events of
ragnarok yet then there's this version of doctor
strange that we saw during all the trailer footage
his robe seemed like a way darker version of his
costume from the first doctor strange movie
even his cloak of levitation is kind of black
instead of red and if you look at some of the
footage there's a lot of doctor strange footage
during this he seems like a way more disheveled
version of himself and there's a lot of different
footage of him going through a lot of the same
beats from the first doctor strange movie like
he finds the sanctum he sees all these mystical
things there's this giant library that he starts
learning magic from but then you see this evil
shadow version of himself seemingly rise up and
he winds up fighting a version of himself amidst
this crumbling reality like you see the visage
of new york behind him this big landscape that
seems like it's been eaten by another dimension
but then for whatever reason it seems like this
darker version of doctor strange who's just
freaking out all over his trailer footage here
darkest timeline doctor strange is then fighting
what looks like the regular version of doctor
strange in a costume that seems much more akin
to his regular mcu costume so the fact that
they're saying that this version dr strange
the darker version winds up on the guardians of
the multiverse team this multiverse avengers group
makes it actually sound like he's the protagonist
of this episode in whatever's going on with
his reality crumbling around him he winds up
fighting the regular version of doctor strange
the trailer footage can be very misleading just
because it's meant to be as crazy as possible
and whatever his character arc he could just be
driven to a darker place after the events of what
happens during the episode and just to explain
killmonger coming back so this is michael b jordan
who's going to be doing the voice for this they're
getting pretty much all the mcu actors from the
live-action movies to come back and do the voices
for the animated versions of their characters
so michael b jordan already came back and recorded
dialogue as killmonger for this alternate universe
version of killmonger but a lot of people been
asking him about coming back in black panther too
and obviously they just made the big reveal the
title of black panther 2 is black panther wakanda
forever so when you hear michael b jordan is
already coming back to do more killmonger you have
to remember that it's actually for an alternate
universe version of the character for this
marvel what if series in future seasons of what if
because it sounds like he'll be back in season two
as part of this larger team of multiverse avengers
the really cool thing about the what if series
though is that it gives you an idea for what the
mcu is going to be doing and say like seven or
eight years because we've all been talking about
them building up to an avengers secret wars movie
way down the road like it's such a big concept
that it would take them a long time to build up
to something like that many different versions
of all the different characters in live action
it's a very rick and morty approach to the marvel
cinematic universe which also consequently is kind
of what they're doing during the loki episodes
i'll be doing videos for all those episodes in
a couple weeks when it starts what'll probably
happen though is that the what if episodes will
wind up starting after the black widow movie is
released in july so maybe like a late july release
for the series and it'll run for 10 weeks i don't
know when season 2 is supposed to be released i'm
assuming next year sometime but everybody let me
know in the comments if they're doing a multiverse
avengers story across multiple seasons who else do
you want to see on that team and which alternate
versions of the characters do you want them to
include there's been a rumor that there's going
to be a venom 2 trailer coming sometime next
week if there is of course i'll totally do a
video for it but be sure to subscribe so that you
don't miss any of those videos you can click here
for my brand new doctor strange 2 Wandavision
deleted scene video in alternate ending that
we just learned about and you can click here
for my last big venom two teaser trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!